leistung ist ihr schicksal
spitzensportler baut ihre karriere
spätestens seit dem teenager-alter
schritt für schritt auf ich bin wenn der
flug 29 jahre alt kommen aus berlin und
bin seit dem zehnten lebensjahr rechner
leiterin berlin vier bis fünf mal die
woche trainiert sie für ihren sport wenn
der flug war schon bei den olympischen
spielen 2014 dabei über 3000 und 5000
meter wurde sie jeweils elfter
er ist ja auch neue muss man sich
beweisen auch in relativ jungen jahren
schon man kämpft um kaderstatus
um finanzielle unterstützung die dann
dadurch dran hängt und ja das lernt man
über die jahre kennen und man lernt
immer mehr zu schätzen und es wird halt
die älter man wird und je höher der
leistungsdruck wird und in welchem
bereich man dann unterwegs ist einfach
immer härter der leistungsdruck ist teil
des geschäfts derzeit nicht schafft
fliegt raus aus dem nationalkader und
verliert finanzielle förderungen wegen
einer schweren knieverletzung schaffte
sie es nicht zu olympia 2018 nach
pyeongchang auch ihr status als
sportsoldatin wackelte während ihrer
verletzungszeit sportpsychologin
franziska wen holt kennt die probleme
der athleten ohne kaderstatus würdest du
da auch die den status der sportsoldatin
verlieren das natürlich schwierig weil
du ja weiter trainierst also das nicht
so einfach du kannst soldaten bleiben
aber der status sportsoldat wo du
sozusagen freigestellt wirst du für dein
training das trend nicht mehr so einfach
ohne leistung also keine förderung bei
den deutschen meisterschaften 2018 in
inzell wurde sie aber über 5000 meter
schon wieder dritter wie schafft man es
aus so einem teil wieder heraus und dann
habe ich mir ein sehr gutes umfeld
geschaffen mit rehabilitations trainerin
am olympiastützpunkt her und
mentaltrainerin meine familie mein
heimtrainer und alle haben mir zur seite
gestanden haben gesagt geschaffen
dabei ist leistungsdruck kein hindernis
sondern wird als werkzeug verstanden
sportpsychologen arbeiten deswegen mit
athleten an bewältigungsstrategien
dieses druck empfinden ist sozusagen
förderlich ist eine ressource die ich
habe und dementsprechend kann ich dann
auch auf den punkt kommen wenn eine
athletin in meiner beratung ja gesagt
hat ich bin immer so aufgeregt vor
wichtigen ereignissen dass ich fast
kotzen muss da habe ich sehr herzlichen
glückwunsch
weil ohne diese aufregung wirst du keine
olympiasiegerin rente flugs ein neues
altes ziel sind die olympischen spiele
diesmal 2022 in peking
es wird wohl ihre letzte chance sein
dann mit 32 jahren vielleicht doch noch
eine olympische medaille zu gewinnen
muss verrückt sein um leistungssportler
zu sein glaube ich also ich denke die
wenigsten ganz ruhigen typen kommen so
an die spitze muss schon verrückt sein
muss
durchhaltevermögen haben dabei ist
leistungsdruck dem eisschnelllauf noch
einigermaßen überschaubar
in anderen sportarten wie fußball geht
es noch viel intensiver zur sache es
gibt einen unterschied zwischen den
sportarten ob ich im profi bereich
unterwegs bin oder ob ich in diesem
bereich leistungssport und kader
bundeskader sport bin die profisportler
die bauern gerne karriere auf um den
sport und wollen mit dem sport geld
verdienen das heißt die gucken nicht ob
sie parallel noch eine berufliche
karriere aufbauen
und darauf setzt auch wenn der flug die
parallel grundschulpädagogik studiert
später also lehrerin werden möchte gibt
so viele schöne sachen aber auch viele
sachen die man entbehrt glaube ich und
das sind einfach sachen die dann
irgendwann wenn ich mal nicht am
heiligabend vielleicht früher aufstehen
muss dann sage ich ach schön
leistungsdruck im spitzensport ist eine
wichtige triebfeder wenn er gut
kanalisiert wird und das beweiden
athleten die band der flug regelmäßig